so what I hopes is that such a question
could be answerable someday but I think
we have to really dig a little bit
deeper
I mean analogy that people kind of make
is go back far enough in history and you
find people trying to understand what
life is and they didn't have a
definition of life but now with a lot of
additional insight into biology we talk
about cells that divide there's genes
they replicate there's now a lot of
mechanistic underpinnings allow us to
have a much better understanding of what
life means that if you go back 500 years
people would not have even had the
language to survive those phenomena
because they didn't know it the
phenomena where consciousness remains
elusive even to define an operational
way much less to explain the workings
and how it occurs or to causally induce
your creative part of what I think we
have to do is to understand that process
because of course all reality that we
are aware of that awareness process
occurs through this thing that we
haven't yet got an operational
definition of what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Alan sockin
we're on-site at the transformative
technology conference for our second
partnership with them we're super pumped
and honored to now be talking with dr.
Edward Boyton hi ed hi how are you
thanks for coming on the program good to
be here man this is gonna be so much fun
and you are obviously extremely
fascinated with the nature of reality
why we're even here what this all is
about are we really all one well kind of
depends where you draw the boundaries
between things right part of the problem
with the nature of reality is we have so
much undefined words right so if you're
talking about one let's say we do
interpret that as a being let's say I
have my consciousness and you have your
consciousness per the problem is we
can't define consciousness in an
operational way you can't measure my
consciousness I can't measure yours I
could for all you know be a very
accurate robot sitting here right now
right I'm not actually but but
disposable so I think part of the
problem with dealing these questions is
there are a lot of things that are sort
of undefined
and one of my hopes is that by studying
things like the brain we can find the
otherwise invisible workings of the
clock the gears and the machinery that
underlies these things and start to
understand how they yield functions like
consciousness and awareness and
cognition and feeling so what I hopes is
that such a question could be answerable
someday but I think we have to really
dig a little bit deeper
I mean analogy that people commonly make
is go back far enough in history and you
find people trying to understand what
life is and they didn't have a
definition of life but now with a lot of
additional insight into biology we talk
about cells that divide there's genes
they replicate there's now a lot of
mechanistic underpinnings allow us to
have a much better understanding of what
life means that if you go back 500 years
people would not have even had the
language describe those phenomena
because they didn't know what the
phenomena were yes there's a tremendous
amount of scientific advancement that is
helping us there is also going back like
you said in history going back even
further than what you were describing
does it all go to one source does it all
go to that big bang or that source or
that all that is or that God or creation
or whatever people want to call it does
it all go back to one hmm
well I guess it kind of depends on what
you mean by one again right so the big
bang of course hypothesizes that from
you know this nothingness fluctuation
you can get everything so maybe goes
back to zero by that definition but
again I think part of the problem here
is you know is this operational
definition question so you can describe
things up to a certain point but then
looking beyond that is the speculation
right so even people who study the first
resilience of a second after the Big
Bang will freely admit that their
theories could not go back before it
right so I think this is the sort of
tension and where science meets
philosophy right and that's actually was
very one of my original motivations you
know when I was a kid I was smart eight
years old I went through a very
religious phase and I really wanted to
understand the human condition because I
felt that you know look at the suffering
look at the misery but also just the
puzzles you know why do we do what we do
and why do we feel what we feel and how
do you feel
but go ahead yeah one of the things I
really hoped was that maybe we could
drive science far enough that we could
have more mechanistic things to say
about yes yes this is extremely
important you're asking our most
important but I guess the way to
summarize what I'm saying is yeah I feel
like we're not ready to answer these
questions but maybe we can get this this
is great this is a marriage of science
and spirituality this is the two sides
of the same coin this is where science
can advance itself to prove some of the
things then there's many things in both
of the fields that have a certain issues
with them even in science that are in a
sense have some sort of perverse
incentives attached to them or whatnot
but let's let's stay with this for a
moment
is everything interconnected well there
a couple ways to look at that so one of
course is the the physics way of looking
at it where things interact through
forces and exchange energy and so forth
and and so they're sort of a way of
describing the connectedness between
things then it's also sort of almost
sort of a computational level you know
Turing Alan Turing the computer
scientists famously proved that you know
the halting problem that you can't with
an algorithm predict whether a computer
program is going to halt or not in the
context of a Turing machine and so one
of the things that is sort of a new
stage they go well are they're
fundamentally unpredictable things or
with enough information can you read
what's going to happen and I guess the
way that such things are interpreted has
to at the end boil down to connectedness
between things how they interact and so
forth yes and another way to even dive
potentially into something that when our
children are born into the world if the
rete if the realization is passed on to
them from their parents as well as the
community the social fabric around them
there is profound awareness shifts that
happen when we're instead of when we're
born and we think you're separate you're
separate you're separate that you think
of things and you feel things like the
air that I'm breathing in is the air
that phytoplankton the trees are
breathing out this water that I'm
drinking this Apple that I'm eating
these things are powered by the Sun and
that's what gives me
the energy that cycle of
interconnectedness is unprecedented and
it's it's in science it's just it's in
science and in spirit and that's where I
feel like those things marrying right
there
it just it transforms our society I
think potentially faster than anything
else would it could it potentially be
that then those feelings of separation
that many of us feel at times would
those feelings of separation potentially
be a root of one of one of the roots of
so many of the problems that we have in
our world when it's another way to look
at your question is are we
interconnected and how but a way to flip
that question his head is what can we do
about it
other ways to be more interconnected yes
so I've been meditating a lot over the
last 10 years and recently been talking
to friends and colleagues and try to
learn in other meditations than the ones
that I've been practicing and so there
are meditation is where you imagine
visual or visualize yourself merging
into the air and then from the air into
the sky into the forest and and you can
feed herself you know it's very visceral
to me becoming bigger and more
integrated with other parts of the
universe and I was in Norway with my
family in August and was sitting on the
the edge of the the water and felt
myself you know becoming part with the
water and then the waters touches the
mountain and it's a very expansive
feeling so I guess there's one way to
look at it which is here's what we have
and also there's a lot of stuff we don't
know but a third way to look at is we're
gonna do about it yes or a way to
cultivate enlightenment and empathy and
so forth and I guess I go back to how I
thought about science intersected with
philosophy as a child and searching for
ways where they might impact each other
you know one of the ways to look at my
own long-term desires for brain science
is can we end in some kind of more
enlightened state exactly yes yes and I
love how you go to these solutions of
things like practicing the process of
the drop rejoining the ocean this is a
very beautiful and eloquent way to
describe one of the most common
processes that if we train ourselves on
a moment-to-moment basis to be one that
can do
potentially all of the work that needs
to be done to solve so many of the
issues on animals the meta where you
visualize and convey empathy and love on
close friends and loved ones and then
strangers and then to distant people you
even might be wishing you harm and
that's another way to try to transform
one's relationship to others for the
better and and so I've been practicing
that as well and it's it's very
interesting how it changes your
perspective on things and maybe even
changes you yourself yeah a long period
of time these are excellent techniques
like you said there's this strategy I'm
very fascinated with this question and
hearing your answer to it what is the
purpose of this reality so again I kind
of think this is something that requires
us to to delve into things more let me
tell you how I think about it so for me
the biggest question is why do we feel
our feelings and are aware of things in
a way that for example I could program a
robot to you know drop a hot object if
it touched it but it wouldn't feel the
heat the way that you or I feel it and
so far that evades easy description
there are even examples in philosophy
where you could you know the zombie
hypothesis where you know you make a
hypothesis what if somebody had neural
mechanisms that did everything that you
did but they didn't have associated
feeling with them right anyway I guess
what I'm trying to say is that there's
sort of this entity that appreciates
reality and we don't understand much
about it consciousness remains elusive
even to define an operational way much
less to explain the workings of how it
occurs or to causally induce your
creative so part I think part of what I
think we have to do is to understand
that process because of course all of
reality that we are aware of is only
that awareness process occurs through
this thing that we haven't yet got an
operational definition of
this is again this is this continued
push that you've had for the longest
time and this is one of the things that
is so crucial to the ethos of our show
and into the ethos of yourself this
pushing of the edge of what's known in
the world and then as you do that
process it gives you deeper and deeper
insight into all of these profound
philosophical questions about the nature
of reality this is absolutely true and
that's why the process of pushing the
edge is so important
so when you see civilizations edge of
knowledge and you see us pushing it with
the scientific method and trying to
understand more you know you pick the
brain and you pick where you go and you
also have to pick your strategies and
how you kind of chip away at that edge
over time and you only have so many so
much time you only have so many other
people that work in the synthetic
neurobiology lab how do you guys pick
what to do how do you guys pick the
biggest questions that are trying to get
at those biggest ultimate nature of
realities well three thoughts so what is
that people studied the mind through
psychology and the brain through
neuroscience for many years but I think
one of the things that eludes us is
incredible almost unimaginable
complexity of the underlying machinery
and that's what led me when I entered
neuroscience about twenty years ago to
make the hypothesis that we need better
tools better ways to see better ways to
control and better ways to map what the
brain does and that sort of triumvirate
of goals is really what drives a lot of
what we do in our group to invent tools
that can solve those three aspects of
the brain and then to apply them in a
systematic way to see what those hidden
workings do so if you projected forward
a bit you know when I hope says you know
wouldn't we feel a conscious sensation
or when we are making a conscious
decision presumably those states are
being created by processes that occurred
before the state arrived in its
existence and if we could understand
that process maybe that is what leads us
to an operational definition of
consciousness it's elusive to try to
grasp it in this moment of occurrence
but if we can see what happened
before that leads to it that might give
us a unique handle and so that means is
we have to really look at the internal
states of the brain it's not enough just
to look at the outward behaviors because
if I put a coffee cup down and turn my
head to the left that might be a
behavior but it might not reflect what I
was feeling maybe I was feeling you know
anguish over a loss for many years ago
or maybe I'm joyful that you know
tomorrow I'm gonna meet with an old
friend or who knows what so the internal
state is important to study but it's so
hard to grasp you've mentioned this and
you're so focused on it it's the process
of building tools to probe at exactly
that the complexity of that the process
of building a tool that helps people
push an edge makes it so that the edge
can be pushed faster this is a main
important philosophical point that you
carry and that it seems to be that it
basically pushes the edge it makes
crates like a bubbled explosion at the
edge instead of just a tiny little pixel
that's moved at the edge it creates a
bigger bubble of more pixels that open
up thanks to this tool and so then yeah
go ahead well we try to build tools that
have three properties first is that I
really like this concept although it's
also a little bit ill-defined of ground
truth can we find the ultimate
mechanisms and reasons why things happen
boiling down something as complex as a
behavior or an internal state ideally
down to the physics and chemistry that
makes it work the second thing is we
want tools to be easy to use and for
others to be able to learn how to use
them rapidly so when we build a
technology like optogenetics for
expansion across TV or other tools we
try to teach them and spread them to
hundreds even thousands of different
researchers all over the world because
it's a it's try to catalyze serendipity
right you know this is such a complex
problem let's make tools that can
empower many many people in in their own
ways to start to probe these issues and
then finally I want to integrate the
tools so it's not enough to just use one
tool if you see something happen but how
do you know what is the important part
so you need to perturb the system in
order to understand what's really
important and then of course what is the
structure how does the building block
that comprise the structure how do the
building blocks a comprise the structure
make it do what it does so in my hopes
in the coming years is to integrate the
observation of the brain the control of
the brain and the mapping of the brain
into a single unified pipeline that lets
us maybe ultimately this is a bit
speculative but it's a it's a hope to
make a computer model of thinking and
feeling and these other otherwise
elusive concepts so then it could
potentially be at the again this this
word it's so interesting the the chemo
electro Connect dome at that level of
brain mapping could potentially be a
catalog of specific emotion or feeling
or a process of thinking something could
be mapped at that crazy complex level of
what's actually going on in all of the
the brain well let's break it down a
little bit what do we need to know to
solve the brain is it enough just to
have the geometry of the wires to see
how the they're connected up in some
topological mesh do you need to know
every molecule every molecule of water
of oxygen you know those are served to
extremes right now and so one of the
questions of course is well we don't
know for sure what all the mechanisms of
the brain do I mean there are brain
cells that make cannabinoids molecules a
bit like the active ingredient in
marijuana there are brain cells that
make gases like nitric oxide they're
gonna diffuse around that is these
things are important for specific
computations behaviors internal states
the other sensor is we don't know and
part of the problem is we don't have a
full catalogue of what all the molecules
in the brain do so what I hopes is that
we can make very detailed maps but I
think there's also gonna necessarily be
a cycle where we acquire knowledge we
try to synthesize it into let's say a
computational model or derive principles
from looking at the organization of
biomolecules or wires in the brain but
those models will probably initially
fail quite a bit but here's what I hope
for those failure those failures are
gonna be constructive failures they're
gonna tell us what to do next so if you
miss something that can't explain the
data you know even missing something
where cells are far apart can coordinate
their activity well maybe there's some
kinda fusible messenger that connects
them across space and time
that's not apparent in the wiring and I
think we have to open these
possibilities this continued process of
probing into what we think is the
deepest complexities of the brain
continue opening up more and more fields
at the edge that have been we didn't
even think existed we were just doing
the brain mind summit at Stanford and
there was the consciousness day as well
and that consciousness day again was so
mind-blowing there's so many interesting
aspects that we were never thinking of
what does what do anesthetics have to do
with consciousness how can those give us
signals about what consciousness is how
can you actually do something like do a
an analysis of fMRI EEG EKGs all these
different biometric signals from the
body during a state of
interconnectedness during a state of
unconditional love during deep presence
and what would that prove to the world
when you're in that sort of a state what
would your biometrics say when you're in
that sort of a state how harmonic
potentially would it be hmm
well I'm a pretty empirical thinker so I
would take a look at the data and want
to know what does the data say is it
correlating with the state can it
predict a state we don't have a
overarching theory of the brain or the
mind yet so it has to be very
data-driven maybe the signal quality is
good enough that you can correlate a
predictive brain state or a behavior
maybe the signal quality isn't good
enough or maybe you have to invent a new
algorithm you know machine learning for
example of course is sweeping many
fields of science including neuroscience
are there strategies to infer for what
looks like a noisy signal something that
is very powerful but ultimately the
burden of the proof relies on the people
acquiring the data and trying to test
the theory
to do the work and it's hard work but
until we have a overarching theory of
the brain or mind I think it has to be
pretty empirically driven when you
describe your feeling of being it was in
Norway is that right oh and I was doing
that meditativeness that was in Norway
yeah when you're there and you're
experiencing the process of your drop
rejoining the ocean of all that is what
do you what was going on in your
biometrics hmm why wasn't monitoring
anything but I felt very calm and I felt
joyful I wasn't monitoring into great
detail but I seem to recall my heart
rate you know stabilizing and so forth
so there's lots of physiological
correlates of these states I guess the
big question is are any of these states
are they these physiological correlates
causal it's an interesting way in other
words you know sometimes there's always
the question of do you have the
causality inverted I think I'm doing a
and it results in B but how do you know
that B is not feeding back in causing a
and I think part of that question here
is that we might need technologies that
not just let you map and look at the
brain but connect it to the rest of the
body of course since there's a lots of
people who are investigating the gut
brain in relationship now circle a
figure they might even have pathology
consequences you know there's a theory
now that maybe changes in the gut could
lead to Parkinson's disease so there's a
lot of realization that we have to think
of the brain as a focal point but it's
not the only focal point we have to
think of the body as a system and then
of course humans create systems together
you know I may be born with very little
knowledge of X Y or Z but I read a book
right talk to somebody and suddenly have
acquired essentially what somebody else
in their life figured out or some set of
people figure it out yes so at least
these concepts like extended
intelligence right as America's you know
we're talking about this edge of
knowledge which is literally pushed by
the hundred billion humans before us
that built this world that we live in
that's why it's so far out right now
well that's part of why also when we
build a tool we want to give it to
hundreds or thousands of other
scientists because you know if we
monopolize the technology and make a few
paltry discoveries you know in a small
academic group well wouldn't that's
what's the point of building such a tool
we should try to help yes
spread it because otherwise the
probability that a line of inquiry might
end without reaching a satisfactory
conclusion goes up yeah I love the focus
on democratization of the tools that
push the edge so important
super-important these feelings of you
said joy calm these feelings that you
have when you're in these states of
interconnectedness could it be that your
biometric readout is actually when I
feel deep states of interconnectedness
potentially the same as my biometric
readout well it's a good question I mean
um
everybody's different of course and
there are ways to classify people's
personalities of course and and how
people react to things people react to
stimuli in very different ways right
they're people who when they hear music
will get shoals go around run another
spine and the people who you know music
doesn't do a lot for them so I think the
question you're asking could be turned
on its head a little bit and ask well
what are the differences in the human
condition you know how many different
kinds of experience do we have and this
is a very hard question to answer I mean
even old philosophical questions like is
the red you see differed from the red I
see are very difficult to confront or is
this when we do see that red is it could
it be a very similar biometric readout
and even it is though what does it mean
so if there's a biometric readout what
is its use or what is its explanatory
power the power I think of them the most
important biometric readout is the
biometric read out during states of
interconnectedness or unconditional love
or deep presence and then seeing if that
same biometric readout is applicable to
when you're feeling it or when Brady's
feeling it because if it is that is so
powerful for us to be able to figure out
who is actually enlightened and who is
not and why is that important well who's
leading our governments who's leading
our corporate
around the world who are the
billionaires around the world and how
deep have they went into these feelings
of interconnectedness and if they
haven't yet then maybe it's important to
help catalyze that just like it is on a
grassroots level for people to have more
feelings of interconnectedness well one
thing I thinking a lot about is also
whether the feeling of something relates
to the actual something so there are
people doing experiments where you know
they'll give them a task and some people
feel like they're really good the task
and sometimes like they're not good to
task and there are a lot of people into
this question do feelings of
understanding or other other interesting
properties of estate do they correlate
with actual understanding and so forth
this is what am I where my concerns is
maybe there's a disconnect there you
know there might be green who feel angry
understand and our epithet ik and so
forth but yeah yeah are they really and
then this is exactly why if we can
figure this out which we will figure
this out I'm very confident that we will
get this it would be able to showcase
when someone is doing this intellectual
masturbation around saying I am feeling
interconnected versus actually being
able to read out there biometrics and
prove whether or not they are and then
it can also be a good feedback loop for
people that are actually trying to train
their states of interconnectedness to
know exactly what you were talking about
it's actually landing that if that
feeling or rather not and it could be
based on the biometric state of the body
and this is I think such an important
place in it this is like if not one of
the most important things I think about
neuroscience and just about this
beautiful divine body that we all get to
adventure into consciousness in can we
figure out what is going on in the
biometrics of the body the heart that
got the brain as we were talking about
when there are feelings of
interconnectedness when there are edy
you know this you have children when you
have children it's a game-changer when
your wife gives birth this is a
game-changer your your consciousness is
shifted to brand-new dimensions it's
never been in before all of a sudden you
become interconnected with this child
even / before you wouldn't it was the
gestation process was happening do you
those feelings of interconnectedness can
potentially be quantified and then more
deeply understood and then again this
process of can I really tap deeper into
the water I drink the food I eat through
the air that I breathe do I feel this is
the process of interconnectedness
because if I do can that potentially
solve so many of the the world's
challenges that we face maybe I think
one of the reasons to attracted me to
try to see how science without
philosophy is also it could be that we
need a much more precise description of
some of these things in order to make
progress so part of the problem with how
we think about economics or psychology
or or these phenomena that we engage in
as humans is also that there's a lot of
underlying machinery that can sometimes
be in a chaotic state right it's you can
describe things at an outward level
using things like biometrics and and
external observation but it can make it
or it can be difficult to understand
because the internal processes that
you'll do biometrics you know could be
far more complicated you know for
example I might in my mind have a whole
series of events as my mind wanders
which lead me to think about you know
even in Norway earlier so I think about
water and then fish and then salty
tastes and then and then I eventually
pick up the glass of water and your
biometric analysis we conclude something
about my hand muscle moving but you
would not have known it anything about
Norway and fish and salt at a very high
resolution level this is why I focus
about two on the brain because I think
we need to find those internal
mechanisms and work
Kings that generate these outwardly
manifested yeah
biometrics yes I've been focusing only
on these external metrics in in a sense
I love seeing it as a big catalog a big
library of states of consciousness and
the insane mechanisms that are happening
in the brain at all of those different
states of consciousness and at the most
highest resolution level that would be
incredible to have that and it requires
the pushing of the edge like like you
and your team do this is another this is
so related to what we were just talking
about regarding what this incredible
initiative of brain mind is doing these
new funding vehicles this is not
sometimes it's just not something that
is venture back a bowl that's gonna give
you some return over a period of years
but it requires something different
sometimes scientific advancements
require different funding strategies
speak speak to the different funding
vehicles that you see that are evolving
there's a need to address two things one
of course is that really great science
is often unpredictable because if you
could predict it fully then you know is
it really necessary right you really
knew the answer the other thing of
course is if you want to take it to
knowledge or discovery and mature to the
point of helping people in everyday life
then that does require some deployment
or often commercialization or
dissemination effort so part of what
everything a lot about is how to connect
those early-stage exploratory
serendipitous events to the value that
people eventually yeah will appreciate
and so you know today I talked in the
seminar that I gave have been about this
three-part model an event a deep science
tool optogenetics perturb the brain
expansionary complicated map the brain
help other people make discoveries with
it yes there's Alzheimer's there's
depression there's schizophrenia there's
basic questions like what is it motion
or what is a feeling yeah and then once
you have a deep understanding deeper
than previously possible ideality then
that's the time to go and design the
innovation or attention that goes out
into the world and this model we've now
applied in a number of contexts
and it's been very very exciting tool
democratize and then do the intervention
yeah yeah yeah that a lot and so so the
the the tension in the funding of course
is how do you connect the value in stage
3 when the ultimate invention gets out
to help you know in the clinic and to
recognize the scientific tool that
yielded it all back in the beginning yes
and fund that so it's almost as though
you have to sell as a propose down the
line value that your immediate family
members are going to get these these
tools of assistance with their potential
neurodegeneration or any neuropathy or
what-have-you
or pathology of any sort and just sell
them on that vision at the earliest
stages for your process of tool
development but the problem is because
there's two leaps that you have to make
it's very hard to see that connection so
I think one possibility would be to
explicitly build such a network what if
there were a large number of scientists
who would take new tools and apply them
lots of problems you know if we started
making maps of I don't know all diseases
or something right to set up a really
ambitious goal and then we're gonna
build these imaging tools I will yield
the maps so now I've connected the
technology to the potential for
discovery and then of course can we
connectives for discovery to the third
stage the design okay if we have maps of
all the diseases we're gonna get drug
targets in mind and billy be able to
build more targeted pharmaceuticals than
ever before you know most drugs are
pretty messy brain drugs amongst the
messiest of all in terms of side-effects
but if we had a map though he's like
said look this targets in these seven
brain circuits but not these other 34 we
might be able to design a new technology
that could be deployed into the medical
world that would be ultra specific this
is just an idea now I like this if
anyone to me it's it's as though if we
create the the just a better knowledge
graph then we can show that we can sell
more easily the actual story and also
helps over time to have track record -
yeah yes we started doing there a
technology which was before Naruto and
technology was cool a lot of people
didn't buy it and a lot of engineers I
felt thought that the brain was a little
bit too nebulous you know if
really wanted to be a bioengineer you go
after DNA right that's the fundamental
thing and then also I think a lot of
neuroscientists at the time distrusted
technology there just weren't that many
technologies that were that useful in
everyday life you know there was like a
couple things that in the last as a
couple decades before we started trying
to crank these technologies out in a
serial fashion that achieved widespread
use and so but one way to make it
possible is to be very concrete about it
you know what let's make it
employability into the scientific
community a goal yes and keep that in
mind at the forefront I love that I love
that ed that's so huge I'd I want to hit
you with this question this question is
now so close to again our hearts well
you know in the question of what is the
purpose of all this is humanity a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence well I think there's a lot
more than just intelligence you know
suppose you had a robot that was just
like you it was as intelligent as you it
could do everything you did but it
wasn't aware would you would you rather
have around on earth you know that or
you know you with your awareness what if
the digital super intelligence is both
intelligent and aware so again it goes
back to the lack of an operational
definition of consciousness we don't
have a consciousness meter we don't know
how to create consciousness so I don't
know the answer to your question
you created consciousness with your
children uh I think it's probably a
stretch to say that I created the
consciousness right you know maybe cells
divide and over time they form a brain
and then the brain were a part of it but
but if you if you think like that then
part then you could say that this water
created consciousness because of that
water that people wouldn't be produced
right so I don't know if this okay well
this is the interconnectedness of
everything yeah but if you're willing to
do that water creates consciousness then
it's very scientifically or is psychism
was all i really consciousness so again
i don't know if we can just as you get
measure to create it I don't know how to
answer that question interesting yeah
there's there's a lot of ways to wander
down that that digital super
intelligence conversation
and plenty more times to endeavor into
the nature of reality as we both dive
deeper into you know our understandings
of what this all is yeah last question
sure what is most beautiful in this
reality I can only pick one thing what
is most beautiful egg well you know
earlier we talked about family and
children and I think that the beauty of
that is sort of multi-dimensional one of
course just the direct emotional
connection you know with a spouse or a
child but then also the neuroscientists
it's been fascinating also to watch
aspects of personality emerge so our son
is almost 10 and our daughter just
turned 7 and to watch their creativity's
and storytelling abilities and and
personalities and and goals emerged as
distinct entities is fascinating so I
think you know the beauty here is
multi-dimensional there's the emotional
level also the intellectual level and it
it makes me even more want to sort of to
achieve those twin goals that you know I
talked about the seminar earlier to
figure out how we can heal suffering
through ground truth mapping of what's
going on in the body and the brain but
also understand you know the human
condition you know why do we do what you
do what is the brains doing when it
generates our minds and we so many
unanswered questions there so I think
our interview I had a lot of responses
where I said well we just don't know
maybe we should redo the interview in 20
years okay here's here's what we figured
out and other famous one was let me go
flip that question on its head let me
rephrase it but yeah that was your other
one no I think it's important it's
extremely important kind of how we
approach a lot of our problems right
somebody comes to us it says oh we need
a better I'm just gonna make this up but
about a surgical instrument actually
this actually did happen people came to
us and wanted better so many surgical
instruments we started thinking what if
we just made the brain stimulation
non-invasive so you wouldn't need three
it mmm so trying the question I was head
yes and trying to understand is there a
deeper question under
the overlying question is one of the
methodologies that we routinely practice
and it's one of the reasons that we can
as we talked about earlier try to aspire
to tools that get down to the ground
truth yeah I think this like the old
saying you know if Henry Ford asked
people what they wanted they would have
all Sayed said they wanted faster horses
right there because they didn't have the
concept of the automobile in their minds
so do you want level deeper is that the
core of school everything we do yeah
yeah I like that a lot it okay you have
two kids what are you gonna recommend
them as a skill to learn going into this
age that we're all endeavoring into well
I think a lot of the things that we've
been talking about I I think can be made
into learn of all teachable skills
dealing one level deeper trying not to
make too many assumptions trying to
think of alternative strategies to what
is the current accepted path thinking
from first principles as much as
possible it's not just an incremental
building in front I passed data point
but what's really going on under the
hood and when you get to that
fundamental truth yeah those are huge
and thank you very much for joining us
on the show Greg's been an honor it's
been a pleasure yeah thank you so much
for coming on whoa such a good one
really appreciate you thank you ed
thanks everyone for tuning in greatly
appreciate would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode all the different topics that we
talked about regarding the nature of
reality in neuroscience check out the
links in the bio below synthetic
neurobiology org also ed Boyden org and
Ed's Twitter profile check those out
check out the links in the bio below to
the transform of Technology conference
as well check out those links support
them we'd love for you to do so also
thank you very much
Brady Springer for Co producing the show
really appreciate you brother thank you
very much
check out the links in the bio below two
simulations support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations around the world that you
believe in support them help them grow
you can find all of our links below
patreon cryptocurrency paypal you can
design cool merch check you pay dolls
links to below and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world you love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon and check it in 20 years we
have the answers to some of these
questions for two twenty years
[Music]
you
[Music]